so uh so like what uh are your biggest
like media vehicles
like that that's a that's a manager
question uh one of my biggest media
Vehicles yeah I mean like like yeah
like the things that you've done that
have really launched you I always say
well that's the weird thing about the
biz now is you know I'm I'm doing comedy
16 years or so and it was all about be
funny have a good material write new
stuff and now it's like you gotta go
viral you gotta have a tick tock you
gotta have a podcast you gotta have a
sketch thing you gotta have a sitcom
idea so for me I think it was stand up
and then putting the stand up online
that's the key because The Gatekeepers
they weren't touching a lot of us for a
while so right we I put my YouTube
special on YouTube and that at the time
it was a failure like oh I couldn't get
Netflix to buy it on YouTube and it it
did well and then I finally sold tickets
oh really that's what yeah what does
more for your like being on Conan back
in the day or being on Rogan oh no
by many miles I've done nine Conan's
didn't move the needle really right yeah
one Rogan
yeah yeah that that's for sure and then
you opened for Seinfeld yeah which
that's great for me you know it's an
honor I'm a huge fan but uh that doesn't
move the needle either yeah yeah you
know Comics like hey that's cool man and
I'm like yeah my mom liked it but uh
doesn't help sell tickets it's all about
its own tickets yeah right and then you
toured with Seinfeld or did was he
mainly in like uh New York instead we
had we did four shows at the Beacon
highlight of my life best weekend ever
what's the beacon the Beacon's the big
it's our one of our big beautiful old
theaters on the upper west side okay and
that's where he always works out and so
for me to open for him there it was like
a dream it's like 3 000 seats it's
beautiful and ornate that's where he
works out that's so great oh I know it's
like the Wilbur in Boston right yeah I
like that but but no The Wilbur is way
small they're well they're like old and
Mystique yeah yeah and famous you know
like that's where uh Allman Brothers
will play or something and it's a great
theater so that was great and we had all
these dates on the books pandemic hit so
that sucked and you made a [ __ ]
Pop-Tart movie
so I haven't talked to him in a while
the uh Comedians and Cars Getting Coffee
like uh that
is insanely that that would move the
needle if you yeah that would help well
there's like eight of them and they're
all on Netflix like during the pandemic
prime time I feel oh I watched it all I
love that show Michael Richards one is
great oh shoot they address the n-word
stuff really yeah I mean you would kind
of have to yeah I feel they did it on
Curb Your Enthusiasm one of the seasons
for the Remake and they're like uh they
kind of made a joke about it
right I mean you would have to you
couldn't I mean like if we had Michael
Richards on the podcast he couldn't like
dance around that no that's a big big
n-word in the room
but that's the weird thing about cancel
or whatever you want to call it is
Michael Ridge did that I don't know what
was that 10 years ago it was 2006. okay
wow it was it was actually pretty
[ __ ] rare for there to be a video
camera yeah on a cell phone right right
that's what got him I think that that
the size of that file was in the
kilobytes uh yeah well it kill a bit his
career
uh yeah so the problem is like if you
murdered somebody and went to jail for
20 years and then came out you'd society
would go hey you did your time you're
rehabilitated here's a busboy job but
what he did I don't know if you can ever
shake that that's the irony about our
justice system yeah now it's like in the
hands of the people instead of like a
courtroom I wonder
um because he was like killing it in
movies wasn't he like on problem Childs
wasn't he like the bad uncle on Problem
Child UHF uh-huh he did a lot of stuff
and then you don't see him at all
anymore yeah
but you know it's a shame
the N word it's really gnarly too like
that was just an odd way to address a
Heckler I know I know really that video
got me in a comedy yeah no no but uh 16
years years ago was
2006. so that and and the first time I
ever tried stand-up was 2006. oh nice
yeah so it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of Amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on Amazon and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude